hallo liebe leute wir möchten euch heute
ein laden ein partner von uns zu werden
wie ihr vielleicht schon mal gesehen
habe gibt es nicht nur easy german
sondern auch easy languages vor vielen
jahren haben wir angefangen straßen
interviews zu machen und das bei youtube
hochzuladen und damals haben uns einige
leute geschrieben ob sie das auch in
ihren ländern machen können
und das machen wir immer noch
mittlerweile haben wir schon diese art
von videos in über 30 sprachen
produziert und wir möchten auch euch
einladen bei dem projekt mitzumachen als
corporate news herr von easy languages
produziert ihr eure filme in ihrer
eigenen sprache
und hier sind vier dinge die ihr braucht
um mitzumachen
das erste ist ein grundsätzliches
interesse am filmemachen
ihr müsst nicht unbedingt vor erfahrung
haben denn viele leute die angefangen
haben filme zu produzieren zum beispiel
anja und griechischer von easy waschen
hatten vorher wenig erfahrung und nicht
mal eine kamera zum drehen und haben
dann mit uns angefangen das ganze könnt
ihr online lernen und wir unterstützen
euch dabei was braucht ihr noch ihr
braucht ein bisschen zeit dafür
also ihr solltet wissen ob ihr diese
zeit habt denn man kann natürlich ein
oder zwei videos produzieren darüber
freuen wir uns auch sehr aber falls ihr
regelmäßig produzieren möchte muss man
schon ein paar stunden pro woche
investieren
es muss nicht super viel sein aber wenn
wir zum beispiel jede stunde jede woche
drei bis vier stunden hat ist das eine
super voraussetzung dafür mitzumachen
ihr braucht ein basis equipment aber das
muss nicht viel sein
es könnten auch zum beispiel zwei handys
sein es sollen nicht ganz alte handy
sein das können vielleicht ein paar
mittel gute handys seien aber schon mit
so einem iphone oder einem guten samsung
von kann man eine gute qualität für
youtube produzieren und mit einem
zweiten handy kann man die interviews
machen
vielleicht habt ihr das schon mal
gesehen dass leute so ein handy als
mikrofon benutzen und später wird das
synchronisiert ihr braucht also nicht so
ein profi equipment wie
wir um anzufangen und es kostet euch
auch nicht viel
das vierte was ihr braucht um
mitzumachen ist ein team
ihr müsst nicht unbedingt ein team haben
denn ihr könnt auch die videos alleine
drehen
so machen das zum beispiel horan von esi
spanish oder toni von esi friends sie
gehen tatsächlich manchmal alleine auf
die straße und sprechen dann einfach
menschen an und fragen sie ob sie
mitmachen aber im team macht das ganze
natürlich auch mehr spaß also wenn ihr
freunde hat die auch interesse haben ist
das auf jeden fall eine coole
freizeitbeschäftigung und natürlich
hilft es auch bei der verarbeitung ihr
müsst nicht alles ganz alleine machen
wenn ihr zwei oder drei leute seid und
jetzt geben wir euch noch vier gute
gründe warum er unbedingt mitmachen
solltet und was euer vorteil davon ist
wenn ihr ein partner bei ysl englische
zeitpunkt 1 ist ihr habt spaß wenn er
rausgeht und mit euren freunden so etwas
cooles macht wie straßen interviews hier
sehen wir wie ja nicht gerade dieses
video dreht er hat unheimlich viel spaß
punkt zwei ist ihr lernt etwas neues und
zwar etwas sehr wichtiges wenn man in
der lage ist interviews zu machen videos
zu verarbeiten und auch fotos zu machen
wenn videos und fotos machen ist auch
ein sehr ähnliches gilt das sind etwas
das sind fähigkeiten die man heutzutage
im beruf gut gebrauchen kann sehr viel
läuft heutzutage über video sehr viele
geschichten werden über video erzählt
und es kann auf jeden fall nur von
vorteil sein für euch wenn ihr in der
lage seid euer eigenes video zu drehen
der dritte punkt ist ihr tragt zum
kulturaustausch bei uns ist es ganz egal
ob ihr videos in französisch in arabisch
in russisch oder vielleicht in einer
kleinen sprache von der ich noch nie
gehört habe dreht denn für uns ist es
wichtig dass wir alle sprachen und alle
kulturen der welt zeigen und das ist
wirklich unser traum mit diese languages
dass wir die welt so zeigen können wie
sie ist aus vielen nennen
dann haben wir vielleicht nur negative
schlagzeilen
oder wir wissen überhaupt sehr wenig
über diese länder weil sie selten
irgendwo in den nachrichten vorkommen
umso schöner ist es die menschen direkt
auf der straße zu sehen und entweder ein
ganz neues ein anderes oder ein
erstmaliges bild überhaupt zu bekommen
und der vierte grund warum ihr mitmachen
solltet ist dass ihr mit diesem projekt
auch etwas mehr schaffen könnt als nur
ein kleines hobby für uns mechanische
mich hat das ganze projekt vor einigen
jahren als hobby angefangen und wir
haben es einfach aus spaß gemacht und
heute ist es unser beruf wir haben
tausende zuschauer in der ganzen welt
wir reisen rum wir treffen diese
menschen die unsere videos gucken und
wir haben tatsächlich auch viele patches
die uns unterstützen die es uns
ermöglichen das als unseren hauptberuf
zu machen
und wenn ihr jetzt lust bekommen habt
auch ein partner von uns zu werden und
videos in eure eigene sprache zu
produzieren dann würden wir uns sehr
freuen
was könnt ihr als nächstes machen ihr
könnt auf unsere website geben
easy - languages dot org und dort findet
ihr weitere informationen dazu wie ihr
ein co producer von unserem projekt
werden könnt wenn ihr alles durchgelesen
habt und immer noch findet dass das eine
gute idee ist schreibt uns unbedingt in
unser kontaktformular oder direkt an
info at - languages dot org
und dann wird sich jemand aus unserem
team bei euch melden und euch mit
weiteren informationen versorgen wie ihr
euer erstes video drehen könnte ich
persönlich würde mich sehr freuen
demnächst videos von euch aus aller welt
zu sehen und ich freue mich darauf ich
freue mich und hoffe dass ihre macht bis
bald
[Musik]